what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu my name is warren
thompson i'm your host and quick
reminder about our moon night watch
party tonight it will be back sorry i
missed last time but we will be back
tonight we'll be starting at 11 30
pacific time so exciting news there and
exciting news that we may have the exact
release date for the trailer for thor
love and thunder the one that we have
been waiting for for a long time now the
one that has broken the record for least
amount of days between the teaser
trailers release and the actual movies
theatrical release the trailer that has
almost become more famous than the
spider-man no way home trailer of course
nothing will really ever be that i'm
sure the hype around that was insane but
the hype for thor love and thunder is
still very much real especially since we
found out that the guardians of the
galaxy are actually going to play a
pretty decent role in thor love and
thunder we'll talk about that in a bit
but first let's talk about when this
trailer could be coming as it is listed
on a website an actual release date for
it and of course if you're new and you
want to stay up to date on the mcu and
trailer updates be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so if you caught my video
yesterday you know that the trailer for
thor love and thunder is officially done
they have all the footage that they need
the editing should be done at this point
in time the only thing that's really
left is the voice dubbing which is how
we figured it out that it was complete
marvel voice actor gaurav chopra who
does the hindi voice dub for chris
hemsworth shared a picture to his story
yesterday on instagram sharing that he
has done his work for the voice dubbing
for the thor love and thunder trailer
and that means it's done huge news but
when is it coming well a website that
has been talking a lot about marvel news
recently and has been considered very
very credible is saying that the trailer
for thor love and thunder should be
coming next monday april 18th now
yesterday i actually did mention that
marvel typically releases big trailers
on a monday as long as no other studios
involved like sony they typically
release them very early on in the
morning around 9am eastern time 6am
pacific time and a week for all of the
voicedub actors to get their parts done
and their voiceovers recorded is plenty
of time and they shouldn't be sent the
trailer unless it's 100 entirely
complete that way they can just do the
voice dub and it's done so monday april
18th is looking pretty good now this
website is the brazilian website chipu
and they are claiming that the trailer
is coming april 18th and apparently the
people who run the site are actually
kind of famous in brazil and they are
respected as a reliable source now i
don't know too much about this website
but they have been posting a lot of
exclusive stuff about marvel's face iv
they've talked about she-hulk and black
panther and other projects as well and
those haven't come out yet so we haven't
been able to prove their accuracy or not
but it looks like it will be tested next
monday as everybody is expecting that
trailer to come out thanks to them again
i would be a little cautious on this one
but as far as timing it would make sense
and marvel does like to release trailers
on monday morning and since we have all
of this promo coming out we now have our
first look at gore the god butcher which
was given to us not too long ago we have
a look at ravanger thor and a ton of
different action figures coming out for
thor love and thunder the press tour is
on its way they're talking about thor
love and thunder as we speak it all
seems to be leading up to the actual
trailer's release which i do believe
could be monday and according to the
site it is monday so keep an eye out for
that i'm not saying it's 100 confirmed
since we haven't really proven this
website's track record yet but again
since all of this stuff is kind of
closing and together on the release of
the trailer i do think it's coming next
week and monday would make perfect sense
so let me know how excited you are to
finally see the thor love and thunder
trailer in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news and of course for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter or tick tock as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
[Music]